today I got a chance to hang with the
kids in there groovy Nashville home who
decided that you would come down to
Nashville and hang out during CMA I love
country music so to be here at the HGTV
Lodge with my buddies like and you like
it's so cool the lodge which is part of
CMA fest is a performance space that's
been given a very Brady throwback vibe
from disco balls to 7d snacks I looked
around the kitchen and it's crazy first
of all the fridge is like the fridge but
have you seen what's inside cookie dough
kids before we had smart phones for
selfies in the 70s we use polaroid
cameras along with Chrissy karlie Pierce
and Scotty McCreery are also gonna sing
here is there any chance that you guys
would perform in here I mean we could
Rock Hill Sunday
[Music]
et was first to show you inside the
newly remodeled real brady house in los
angeles the complete reveal will be on a
very Brady renovation premiering on HGTV
this September I feel like now that
you're together you want to be together
forever and that this could be something
that goes on for a while I would love it
I am all for and we definitely and I'm
not even kidding about this we
definitely have to have a sleepover in
the house without cameras
[Music]